c'est parti bienvenue au port pour le
trail des anglais
[Musique]
vous il s'agit du prix qu'il pense à
quoi juste avant on pense à quoi juste
avant le savent très bien faire sur le
cameraman qui est filmé comme la rosée
c'est ça c'est bien que et jette bien
dans la poubelle à leurs locaux bien
remplie fond et bien voilà c'est un juge
au gosier quoi pado tu donnes de l'eau à
tout le monde sait bien et du ha je
pense donc je coure motivé mais l'oeuvre
au matin pour coiffeur c'est vrai bah
oui ça ça change quelque chose tu bosses
au nom aussi moi je crois oui
ouais allait bien bien rares ayant pas
trahi leur père samain je t'encourage
mois entre le diable
c'est bien deux animaux dans ce beau oui
c'est trop gentil et là il ya ton
prochain
c'est beau c'est bon bisous de caméras
grande chaloupe à un endroit stratégique
en belgique par tj oblige arriver
franchement non
[Rires]
ouais j'ai prises afin qu'en mai j'ai
pas dormi avant 23 heures on le désert
donc la question c'est pourquoi ouais
chez moi la clim la chaleur la voiture
fait pas donc pourquoi tu cours
1 comment surpasser pour le plaisir on a
tu as donné la réponse bouge maintenant
si on passe toi lève haut les chemins
les anglais c'est parti pour la merde on
refait les gars n'oubliez pas de boire
[Musique]
il est des nôtres
il a fait son travail comme les abricots
les vrais la jambe
excellent à aller pour nous dimanche
matin la version c'est la danse des
canards
j'aurais bien aimé la beauté ravasi
c'est comme ça que tu es des vies les
coureurs ainsi qu à son mollet la maip
allemand il va écouter les yeux partie
fait voilà un beau geste
c'est bien s'amuser là
[Applaudissements]
ça va pas trop dur les encouragements le
dimanche je passe bien non ces machines
il a des 426 371,1 au jigawa de
belgique miss
hormis la banane mais oui mais elle est
où la banane tout le monde s'éclate à
laquelle tout tout tout ça à l'accueil
le tout tout tout tout le monde annonce
à laquelle était de regarder ce panneau
ça ne s'est pas résumé bercy le silence
de l'effort
ne ratez pas assez fatigué pousse à vous
êtes encore super bilan c'était bien il
enseigne